in this next clip one brave soul
encounters the most fearsome creature in
the world la where radio sidekick luigi
is blindfolded and challenged to put his
hand inside a box with absolutely no
idea what's inside Oh tell me it's not a
sec oh my god it's just taken where's a
movie it's not a snake it's not a dead
rat why no it's a teddy bear so why did
Louise go screwy over a teddy this seems
like a totally irrational response but
he's actually triggering a survival
mechanism which is really important for
us in other situations when we have a
fear response the part of our brain that
reacts is the amygdala it's the fight or
flight center the part that react
immediately as opposed to an area called
the prefrontal cortex which allows us to
think about things a little bit more
carefully before we act oh no no no the
amygdala tells another part of the brain
the hypothalamus to release chemicals
that trigger the fight-or-flight
response which causes luigi's pupils to
dilate his breathing to quicken to
increase oxygen to the body
his blood pressure to increase all these
things that might prepare him to either
fight or run the fight-or-flight effect
is particularly pronounced in Luigi
because he also has a phobia of both the
dark and of being blindfolded so for
Luigi being blindfolded is already a
nightmare that's why he appears a jeté
today even reaches into the box
ha easy Simon